did you know that there are black holes
in the ocean yeah also known as Eddies
these black holes are similar to the
ones we see in space they're essentially
whirl pools that are so powerful nothing
can escape their pull what makes them
even scarier is their size they are
massive some measure up to 150 km in
diameter they're created through a mix
of water at different temperatures wind
and the Earth's rotation and once
they're created they can last for months
or
years yeah though it may not seem like
it the ocean is a much more terrifying
place than the cosmos from hideous
alien-like creatures to the Mysteries
that lie below the sea these are just
some of the reasons why the ocean is
scarier than
space we've yet to discover alien life
but looking at some of these creatures
you might think otherwise unlike our
solar system the ocean is full of
terrifying Wildlife from creatures as
simple as sharks and killer whales to
the more disturbing looking red
octopuses and proboscis worms regardless
of their appearance many of them are
dangerous and won't be afraid to pick a
fight Earth's ocean might be more
mysterious than parts of space for one
we don't really know what the bottom of
our oceans are like and we might just
know more about the surface of Mars and
the moon but NASA is looking to change
that they're slowly mapping out the
ocean floor this might give us clues
about what oceans are like on other
planets it also helps NASA test gear
that will be used in space
missions outer space and our ocean are
more similar than we think both have
high pressures a lack of breathable air
and extreme temperatures but what makes
the ocean scarier it's teaming with life
that can attack and kill you yeah space
is passively trying to kill you while
the ocean is actively trying to kill
you huge destructive asteroids or
meteors heading toward Earth are
incredibly rare but you know what isn't
the ocean coming for us climate change
is causing sea levels to rise at an
alarming rate and if the trend continues
our sea levels could rise over 2 meters
by the year
2100 Coastal communities like Venice
Bangkok and New York City would face
severe floods causing parts of these
cities to be
displaced okay before we keep exploring
the ocean let's talk about a way that
you can explore your mind that's both
free and accessible well this comes from
our sponsor brilliant brilliant is for
all the what if fans who want the best
way to explore topics like math data
science and computer science there's
thousands of lessons that are fun
interactive and accessible just like our
videos I've been learning about solar
energy and I love how the course is sort
of tailored to my level and Pace it's
using bite-sized chunks of information
and has interactive elements to help me
learn quickly and effectively so give
brilliant a shot you can start your
Learning Journey for the first 30 days
completely free and you can get 20% off
by going to brilliant.org Whata if or
click on the link in the
description light works differently in
both space and the ocean in space
without an atmosphere the light is Harsh
and unfiltered this leads to problems
like radiation exposure luckily with our
Advanced space technology we found a lot
of ways to overcome this ocean there's a
lack of light depending on how deep you
go fany are the terrifying creatures
that have evolved made them frightening
looking and potentially
dangerous space has some scary things
that can come for us like solar flares
giant explosions from the Sun that shoot
light energy and high-speed particles
out into space one massive solar flare
hitting Earth could disable all our
Electronics sending us back to the Stone
Age the chances of one hitting us are
incredibly rare though most of the time
they just bounce off our ozone layer but
you know what isn't so
hurricanes if they end up reaching land
entire towns flood tsunamis are much
more
terrifying these massive waves can reach
over 30 m high and once they reach land
they're incredibly dangerous they can
cause severe floods and Destroy anything
on the coast the Indian Ocean Tsunami of
2004 killed 225,000
people no one's ever got lost in space
with an entire support team watching
over you using billions of dollars worth
of technology and GPS systems you can
rest easy knowing you're in good hands
but in the ocean people get lost all the
time just swimming out a little bit
farther than you usually would while at
the beach can leave you stranded unable
to find land the ocean has over 3
million shipwrecks in it making it one
of the most dangerous places on
Earth you you don't have to worry about
random weather attacks in space in the
ocean it's a different story lightning
can strike the ocean at any time it
happens often due to its sheer size and
it being a magnet for lightning when
lightning strikes it can spread for up
to 100 m and this poses a threat to
boats swimmers and sea
life the ocean is full of dangerous
bacteria one of the worst is the flesh
eating bacteria that's found in the warm
parts of the the Gulf of Mexico the
bacteria can get into swimmers open
wounds and cause ulcers on the skin
antibiotics should be able to solve this
issue but it can sometimes get so bad
you need to amputate a limb yeah space
doesn't have anything as scary as
that up in space there's a ton of debris
known as space junk and while there's
some concern about the debris making
space travel dangerous it's not nearly
as concerning as all the garbage we have
swimming around in the ocean in the
North Pacific Ocean there's a massive
island of waste known as the Great
Pacific Garbage Patch it's made up of
mostly Plastics making it almost
impossible to break down as a result
it's harming ocean wildlife and could
destroy entire ecosystems up in space
the debris is monitored closely by space
agencies they're constantly looking at
ways to mitigate the issue but down in
the ocean the problem keeps getting
worse and it'll take a long long time
before it gets any better so although
the vast unknowns of space are pretty
terrifying they don't come anywhere near
to how scary our oceans can be you know
what else is terrifying spending 5
seconds on Venus what Mysteries does
this planet hold well that's a story for
another what
[Music]
if